matinée c'est comme comme respirer je
peux pas m'imaginer vivre sans et si je
m'arrêtais ça serait comme un noyé d'un
coup tu as métaphore est devenu hyper
d'art tu es une très belle patineuse
merci mais j'arrête
j'arrête le patinage je pense que tu as
juste un tout petit peu peur j'ai pas un
petit peu peur je suis terrifiée tu
était parfaite
aujourd'hui quand je te regarde je ne
vois que du potentiel gazier je vais
éclater le genou à la batte de base-ball
ou ça ferait trop tonia
j'ai vu des vidéos thézan c'est une
performance tu avais peur de rien et
regarder des vidéos de moi je pense
faire du porno
ma mère m'en crois capable je veux lui
prouver le contraire
en devoir de la romance de la tragédie
on veut voix du sexe moi ça me va et toi
j'ai l'habitude de patiner seul il me
faut du temps pour m'ajuster
et là c'est sûr j'y mets toi si tu
laisses tomber 4 tu regretteras d'avoir
survécu
honnêtement toi et moi on peut carrément
viser les jeux olympiques
on va pas se mettre la pression
tu seras jamais une championne jamais
t'es sûr que tout va bien
je sens qu'on monte ses coûts
tout le monde peut ouvrir un nouveau
chapitre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]